- I'm Michael Inman.
I'm curator of rare books at
the New York Public Library,
and today, we're looking
at the Hunt-Lenox Globe
which is not only the
second-oldest surviving
terrestrial globe, but
also the oldest known globe
to depict the Americas.
The origin of the globe is still
somewhat shrouded in mystery.
As far as we know, it was
created probably in France
or possibly Italy, roughly
between the dates 1505 and 1510.
There are a number of details on the globe
that I find interesting.
It's a little bit hard to make out,
but here you have a sea monster,
here at the end of my finger,
I can move that down slightly,
as well as a ship.
These are just two examples
of the kinds of details
that are hidden in the globe, in a sense.
The more you look at it,
the more these things do pop out.
And it's here at the end of my finger
that we see, just below the equator,
the Latin phrase, HC SVNT DRACONES,
"here be dragons," or "here lie dragons."
So, today, when you see
a map that's pretending
to be ye olde map and a ship sailing
off the edge of the world,
and it says "here lies dragons,"
that phrase derives solely
from the Hunt-Lenox Globe.
Then we have here South America.
No North America, however.
You see the land mass cuts off right about
where today's nation of Panama is located.
So, the Isthmus of Panama.
Nothing beyond that point is depicted.
Well, the New York
Public Library has about
55 million items in its collection,
and certainly, this is one
of the great treasures.
It has that treasure status because it is
a completely unique object,
and it speaks to Europeans'
knowledge of the world
just shortly after the time
of Columbus's initial voyage.
When working with something like this,
it really does, for me
anyway, remind me of
my tiny, small, little,
individual place in history,
and the fact that I'm just
part of the long continuum
of people who have
interacted with this object,
and that it will be around long after I
and all of us are gone.